hi there today we'll look at hopfield
networks is all you need
by researchers from the johannes kepler
university in linz
and the university of oslo so
on high level this paper proposes a new
type of hopfield networks
that generalizes modern hopfield
networks from
binary patterns to continuous patterns
and then shows that the retrieval update
rule of these new hopfield networks
is equivalent to the attention mechanism
that's used
in modern transformers and
it's actually a more general formulation
of the attention mechanism and therefore
it can be used to do kind of a variety
of things
to improve modern deep learning and uh
it also has a companion paper
where it applies this to some kind of
immunology
research and gets uh achieves state of
the art
in a task that is specifically suited to
this type
of attention all right
let's dive in together we'll go over
what this paper does what it proposes
and
so on if you like pay if you like videos
like this uh
consider subscribing you know sharing it
out and
i hope you're enjoying this all right
also thanks to my discord community
um for you know very helpful bringing me
up to
speed on this paper uh super interesting
discussions there
if you're not on our discord yet uh i
invite you to join
it's fun okay so
what is a hopfield network a hot field
network
is a pretty kind of old style
old conceptualization of a neural
network
so in a hopfield network what
your goal would be is you can
conceptualize it as a bit of a neural
network
so let's say we have five neurons
or something like this uh your what your
goal would be
is to have a neural network where you
can store
so-called patterns and a pattern in this
case would be
a binary string of size five so for
example
one zero one zero zero or
one one zero one zero and you'd have a
list of these patterns
and what your goal would be is to store
these patterns
in the neural network such that and here
you know we'll just consider everything
to be sort of connected to everything
else
and um what your goal would be
in this is that you can kind of store
patterns
inside this neural network and you
adjust the weights
somehow so this was as i said this was
this was this is kind of an
old model um you store you you adapt the
weights
such that you store these patterns and
what does it mean for a pattern to be
stored
if you have stored a pattern you can you
will then be able to retrieve it
and you retrieve a pattern in these kind
of old style
hopfield networks by providing a partial
pattern
so what you'll say is for example i
i want a pattern that starts with one
one zero
and you give that to the network and
there would be a so-called
update rule and the update rule is kind
of an internal
uh rule so let's just go
through this so here this one one zero
maybe this is one
one zero and then they would kind of
send messages around
so this update rule would somehow adjust
the value of this and this neuron here
to what's most compatible with the
network weights
and if if the network weights have been
adjusted correctly
this will turn out then at the end of
applying this update rule
that this is a one and this is a zero
and therefore this pattern here is
retrieved now had i input
uh one zero one at the beginning then
the outcome would be different hopefully
this pattern here
would have been retrieved okay so you
can
see the applications of this like you
can have the first three digits as
sort of a database key and then the last
ones as sort of the value that you store
along with it
and then you can simply provide the
first few you can also provide you don't
always have to provide three
um so this all depends this is
this is sort of an as i said an old
conceptualization of neural networks so
people
were imagining that this is kind of how
the brain works
you know fire together wire together and
also with research into this it it turns
out
that you know you might think you know
there's there's kind of five neurons so
maybe i can store
five different patterns you know
accurately because if i store
too many patterns right if i have many
many many many patterns
then i can't expect
to be able to retrieve all the patterns
again because some of them will just be
so equal
that you know many will start maybe with
this
and and i won't have a chance to to
retrieve
the one i want or if the update rule
will make a mistake so you might think
this might be like five because i have
five neurons or maybe ten because i have
ten connections but
it turns out that um in modern
hopfield networks with the appropriate
update rule
you can store exponentially many
patterns in
these networks exponentially many in the
in the dimension
of the um in the dimension of the
patterns and
here i guess that would be the length of
the pattern so
this is a little bit surprising the kind
of storage capacity of these networks
and we'll this um this paper here
generalizes that to continuous uh
to continuous states so what do we mean
with continuous states
i guess i mean continuous patterns so no
longer is a pattern
a binary string but a pattern now is
a string of floating point numbers okay
like 0.5
1.3 and so on and you know a string of
floating or a
sequence of floating point numbers is
naturally depicted as a vector
okay so our patterns are going to be
different
vectors that we store and um you know in
high dimensions
that the the vectors
will be kind of separated well from each
other as long as we don't have too many
but this paper shows
that all these properties for the modern
hopfield networks that hold for binary
strings
still hold if you go to these kind of
um continuous to these vector patterns
that means you can store exponentially
many patterns in the dimensions of the
vector which is pretty surprising right
because you'd think like you know after
you have one vector
per dimension that you know
after that it might get a bit shaky but
no you can actually store
exponentially many that's pretty
surprising
and this paper is a lot about how to do
that
and the fact that that happens and so on
so
we've talked about update rules for
these um
kind of hopfield networks and i haven't
really specified what that is
i've just said that you know i enter a
pattern and then the network does
something and out comes out comes the
whatever the pattern that matches my
query so this here is called a query
you might already um this is on purpose
like the
kind of overlap between the attention
mechanism
lingo and the hopfield network lingo
we're going to conflate the two to kind
of
make clear where the two overlap if you
don't know what an attention mechanism
is or aren't familiar with it watch my
video on attention is all you need uh
once you watch that
this video will make a lot more sense
all right so in what the update rule
does
is specifically and the update rule
there isn't only one
right there are many different proposals
of hobfield networks
and they all lead to different
properties but what an
update rule does ultimately is it
minimizes what's called an
energy so every type of hopfield network
is associated with an energy function
and this the energy function of the
modern hopfield network for binary
strings
is this energy function right here
so with x x is the
pattern um the pattern this is the kind
of state of the hopfield network
and so these are the the whatever is
stored in the network
and then design here is the query that
you enter
into the network and then the
energy here tells you this
quantity you have to minimize this
quantity in order to retrieve the
pattern that you want
okay now we are never directly
working with the energy as such uh so
what you could do is for example use
back prop or something to
use gradient descent to decrease the
energy but
usually along with an energy
function comes an update function
and the update function is what i've
talked about here like you do something
and then the network does something and
then you get the pattern out
what the network does is it minimizes
its energy function and the update rule
is made such that the corresponding
energy function is minimized so the
energy function is more like a
theoretical
consideration that you say okay here is
my energy function of my hopfield
network
and the there will be a corresponding
update
rule that minimizes that energy function
and if you use that
update rule maybe multiple times then
the energy function will be minimized
and you will have retrieved your pattern
or not if if you have too many patterns
stored
it might also fail right so
they they say what the update rules are
in the
um in the text here for the old hopfield
networks
but we're not really interested in the
old ones we're interested in the ones
that this paper cares about namely where
the patterns that you store in the
hopfield network are these
vectors over our vector patterns and the
query
is also a vector pattern so you want to
store
all of these patterns into the hopfield
network so i'm going to
draw it like this here i'm going to
store it into the hopfield network
and then after that you want to come up
with a query
and the query is like this and
in the case of the binary strings we had
something like well
i sort of know half of my binary string
now
in the vector hop field network it's
more like
well i sort of kind of know the
direction
that my vector should point in okay
and you will re what you want to
retrieve
is the vector that has kind of a large
inner product
okay so if i enter this query into my
hopfield network what i hope is that
this vector here is retrieved now you
see it's not exactly the same vector
like they do point if i translate that
here by i it's maybe
something like this but so they are
different but you want to say well i
kind of know what i want
i kind of want something like this and
then the hopfield network would answer
with ah
i have something like this it's this
right here okay
so you that the connection to attention
mechanism
should become pretty pretty obvious
right now
but you know the um to actually
establish this formally is the
kind of the point of this paper and you
know it's pretty cool to see
so they formulate this new energy right
here this is
the energy of this new continuous
hopfield network um specifically they
have to have this term right here
because they now have continuous states
and continuous queries
uh this if you minimize the energy it
basically means that
your query can never you know go to
infinity because
you have the the query right here in the
energy function
um the update rule is this right here
and we'll look at that in a moment but
remember
the update rule is what you actually
implement in code
so if i if i
have a query right here i plug it in
here
this is the state of my hopfield network
and i
apply this rule multiple times and
out comes the kind of
answer of the hopfield network to my
question
so the i input this and the out comes
this after i update after i apply the
update rule
maybe multiple times right
and interestingly you can already see
that this
here if you rewrite a bunch of these
quantities so if you rewrite the beta
here
which is the softmax temperature in a
way
to be one over square root of d and if
you take
the query design here to be the query
matrix
and if you take the x here to be the key
then this is equivalent to the
update or sorry the attention mechanism
of a modern
transformer so that's the point of the
paper is that
we can look at the transformer attention
mechanism
as a hopfield network
and they have this interesting
this interesting diagram at the end
right here uh so the appendix
you know this is typical i guess sep
ho haita i remember this sailor paper
had like 60 pages of
machine proof appendix this also this
has like 70 page appendix
crazy but at the end of the appendix
you'll find this diagram
right here now usually in an attention
mechanism um
you have whatever the the input is so
you have an input
right here so this is attention
mechanisms
or at least transformers they work on
sequences or sets of
objects and from these you'll generate
three things you'll generate the you'll
generate the queries the keys
and the values now you can either
generate the queries from the same
objects which would be
self-attention or you can generate the
queries from like a different object
over here uh it doesn't it doesn't
matter too much for our discussions but
either you you know have a reference
input
or you have you know this kind of same
input all the way
and then what you do is you use three
different heads or you know three
different matrices to transform that
input into queries keys
and values so i often conceptualize this
as
you have kind of your input set and each
of the input sets
outputs a key
and also each one which would be a
vector
and also each one outputs a query
so i often draw this here
the same sequence and each one outputs a
query
and the query sort of the query
is kind of a request for information
so the key exposes uh sort of
what exposes something about
the input here so this could be a
sentence down here this could be
my cat is very
pretty and
the the the vector the key vector right
here
could encode something like this is a
noun or this is an animal
or anything like this right and the
query
here it could ask for for other things
so
for example since this is cat
this vector right here the query vector
is generated
from that you know token cat
now it could recognize that cat is a
noun
and it could ask the other nodes
to basically say are there any
adjectives
around here because um you know
because i it itself is a noun it's the
object of the sentence
right it could ask are there any kind of
adjectives that describe the object
because
that would be naturally a thing to ask
if you were the noun
you would want to know are there any
kind of modifiers um
for for me so it could output the query
and the query here
could mean you know this direction could
mean adjectives
and you see here the word pretty is an
adjective
so it itself would output a key that
says
by the way i'm an adjective right so
if the cat asks then if this node asks
for an adjective
and this outputs uh the adjective
vector then because the inner product
between the two things
is high this will be routed here so
attention mechanisms basically
information routing that's how i always
describe it
but in this paper we look at it more
like
these here are the patterns that are
stored
in a hopfield network and i
by inputting a query and the dot product
being the update rule of the hopfield
network
i retrieve from the hopfield network i
retrieve
the appropriate pattern that i ask for
okay and then you know the values
the values are simply a modification of
the keys in this
form but a lot of people also do keys
and values to be the same thing
but this routing of information happens
here
where you multiply the queries and the
keys
and then you put a soft max over them
okay
so if you just look from the perspective
of
a single node like this node here this
cat
node what it would do is it would
inner product its own query vector with
all of the key vectors right so it would
build an inner product
with all of these and then it would
normalize it would put it through a soft
max
which will kind of give it a
distribution right so
here would give it like uh so this this
actually matches because ma
well my is also very important for cat
this
this this is just an accident i did not
plan this uh this
here this also well many things match
but
but uh in our example we would just say
that this last one
it's it's not only higher it's also
wider
um it matches very well right
and so the information routing
would route mostly information from this
pretty token to the cat token
which makes sense in our case right this
is the attention mechanism
now sin if we are interpreting this as a
hopfield network
and the update rule here is the dot
product
you can actually think of applying this
rule multiple times
so what happens now if
we and this is where this update rule
comes in
what happens if we take this
distribution
and we don't aggregate the values like
usually we would aggregate the values
by this distribution what if we
aggregate the keys
by this distribution okay what comes out
well if we look at this and you know
let's just assume that this key right
here matches
really well but the others also match a
little bit what would come
out would be a weighted average where a
lot of weight is put
on this particular key so what will turn
out
would be something like something that's
very close to that key
you can see um
i'm going to draw the old key here in
green
and i want to draw the old query in blue
so you see that it's
then whatever comes out is not the query
but it's also not that only key that
matches right
it's kind of a weighted average but with
that key dominating
okay now since you know in a hopfield
network what we would do is
we would go again we would put this
new thing the red thing instead of
the query vector okay so we would use
this aggregated keys this weighted
average
as a new query vector for that node
right here so
duplicate that node over here i'll use
that query vector
again and do the same thing again okay
inner product with all of the query
vectors
and now since this is already an
aggregate
of the query vectors what's going to
happen of course the distribution that's
going to come out
is going to be weighted even more
heavily
into the direction so let's make it even
wider
into the direction of that key that
matches okay
and you can pretty clearly see if i do
that iteratively
um then that will lead to a
situation where everything is like very
low
except that one key will
sort of dominate the distribution and
ultra
high and ultra wide okay and that's how
that's exactly how a hobfield network
works right i would input the query
which would be sort of what i want right
i kind of know what i want okay
and then i apply this rule multiple
times
right and with each time i refine refine
refine until
i decide on a pattern right the hopfield
network is made for pattern retrieval
and these here are the patterns that i
want to retrieve so here
the patterns aren't kind of stored in
the network
beforehand but the patterns are also
generated like
in an attention layer so the keys are
generated
by the previous layer or by these
matrices
but that doesn't matter for the hopfield
network update rule so you
see here that the attention mechanism
can be interpreted as simply one step
making one step of this update rule but
you can
think of making actually multiple steps
and and
retrieving the particular key so
you know deciding on a sort of a hard
routing
of particular information now that
only works if if
there are no other vectors that are
close to that particular key right
so if the query is this and you know the
way i drew it here you can see that
there are
many there is this one and this one and
this one that matches
so technically the way i drew it um
what would happen most likely is no many
no matter how many times you apply your
update rule
it would sort of result in kind of the
average of the three
keys right so because they're all
matching and they would all contribute
to that weighted average
of the query in the next step and then
that means basically
the convergence would be to something in
the middle and that's going to be
a central point of this paper um
in which situation we are so they call
the first
part is retrieving a single pattern and
they call the second
situation where you have multiple
patterns that all
match that are not well separated from
each other they call this a
meta-stable state and it's going to be
pretty interesting to look at
um transform like bert language models
and look at where they actually are are
they actually operating in this
single pattern retrieval mode or are
they operating
in the meta stable state mode
all right so here you can see it in the
diagram the only thing differing
this from a hopfield network sorry from
an attention mechanism
is this branch right here so here you
ask do you want to do
multiple updates after you've you've
multiplied the queries and the keys do
you want to do multiple updates if
yes so if you're in a this hot field
network situation you want to do
multiple updates
then you go back as you can see
and you do you use the keys
together with the output of the softmax
to generate
a new query so this query q here
is now generated from the output here
and the key so the keys are the same
these are this is the same thing it's
just put here twice
okay this is exactly what we discussed
okay i hope that's some somehow clear
that these
the the attention mechanism is simply a
one
step uh hub field network pattern
retrieval
algorithm with a particular update rule
that is that is matches this energy
function that they propose
right here of course they do this you
know particularly
because the update rule that turns out
is the transformer update rule
but um i actually don't know if they
backwards engineered the energy function
to match the transformer or if they
first came up with a continuous
help field networks and then just kind
of discover
that it's like the transformer we'll
maybe never find out okay so
um let's go there are a couple of
theorems i believe there are four
five theorems right here that uh show
that kind of make some points about this
about this stuff
and we'll go through them we won't go
through the proofs or any
you know super in-depth meaning but it's
pretty cool to go
through them and they are proved very
rigorously as i said there's a 70 page
appendix so
have a look at that if you're up for it
okay so they say here we have an update
rule this is our
update rule for our new hop field
networks
so the first theorem they say is the
update rule that we
propose converges globally
if we apply the update rule repeatedly
the energy
for t goes equals infinity and the
energy
will converge sorry the energy will
converge to a fixed point this being a
fixed point
for t of course sorry for t goes to
infinity
yeah if this is a fixed point basically
saying that if i apply
this update rule here over and over and
over again
it will it will make this energy
function
converge to a fixed it will make this
energy function converge
don't want to say anything mistakenly
here or
claim too much but that basically
connects the update rule to the energy
okay so
just showing like this really is the
update rule for that particular
energy function okay now as
as itself it's not super duper
interesting yet
but um now we get to theorem two
so theorem two for the iteration that's
the update rule that we
just looked at we have
we have that um this convergence holds
as t goes to infinity
for some stationary point furthermore
this quantity here goes to zero so that
means
this is the um the update at t plus one
and this is the update at t and the
difference between them
goes to zero so that means not only does
the energy converge
but the iterates themselves convert so
the algorithm actually
converges the individual updates
of the algorithm so this e new at some
point that will no longer change
because the the norm between it and the
previous one will go
to zero you can see that either the
sequence here
converges or in the other case the set
of limit points yada yada is a
connecting
subset this is a bit over the top here
they say okay it can either converge to
a point or it can converge to a
connected subset
but if the loss is finite
then any sequence generated by the
iteration equation three
converges to some fixed point
so you know basically saying that here
we
oh this is not the loss i'm sorry um
no this is the domain never mind
i'm an idiot this is basically saying
that this algorithm
will converge okay
and they define here what it means for a
pattern to be
stored and retrieved and that's for
establishing what the kind of
storage capacity of a hopfield network
is so we've established that the update
rule
minimizes the appropriate energy and the
update rule will converge
at some point which means that we can
you know if it converges we can retrieve
the pattern that it converges to
so now we define how many patterns can
we actually store
for that we need to know what does it
mean for a pattern to be stored
so we assume that we have patterns and
these patterns are called
x okay x i we have n different patterns
each one is called
um x with a subscript
we assume that around every pattern a
sphere is given
so how do we imagine this um
we have these patterns and this is this
is just a space now they consider
patterns of the uh on on a sphere but
we'll
just conceptualize it as this we'll have
a space there are patterns we want to
store
okay and we'll say around every pattern
there is
a sphere okay sphere like this
and naturally the patterns are going to
be
there's going to be a notion of well
separated patterns
and you can imagine this a little bit
like
these spheres won't be touching each
other if these spheres aren't touching
each other
that means that the patterns are kind of
well separated
and that means that if we initialize the
query
remember the query here is a vector that
kind of sort of looks like a pattern
and that means the query is kind of
close to the pattern in some notion of
distance
so if we initialize the query somewhere
in that sphere then
it might if it converges
to that sphere to that pattern then we
retrieve the pattern
okay now it gets a bit more complicated
than this but not much more
so we say a pattern is stored if there
is a single fixed point
inside the sphere to which all points
that start inside the sphere converge
and none of the spheres intersect so the
sphere of
point i doesn't intersect with the
sphere of point j
so that's where we say all these spheres
are non-intersecting
we say x i is retrieved if the iteration
equation three
converged to the single fixed point in
that sphere the retrieval error is the
distance so you'll notice you have two
things you have
x i this is the actual pattern and you
have x i star
this is the retrieved pattern so
these hopf they don't always have to
give you the same thing that you stored
that's part of the the nature of
continuous neural networks whatnot
so for every sphere we say there is a
pattern
there is a sphere now
we as pattern is stored if every
i can start wherever i want in this
sphere okay
wherever i want it will always converge
to a point that's inside the sphere
okay and maybe that point isn't the
pattern that i stored but actually this
point right here but
wherever i start i will always converge
to that particular point
if that's the case then i have stored
this particular pattern
now the fact is i don't retrieve this
particular pattern i retrieve the blue
thing
but i can then define the error of
retrieval the error of retrieval is
simply the distance
between the two things ideally this
distance is very small right
but you know we can't can't guarantee it
now there are going to be theorems that
deal exactly with this retrieval error
but first you can see that
here if if these spheres
become larger
you you can't accurately store a pattern
anymore
so this is the kind of ideal situation
but there are also situations
where these spheres you know if i have
these patterns right here
these spheres are so large kind of the
the attractions of the patterns are so
large that if i start
let's say here then i don't converge to
either of these two patterns i converge
to like something in the middle
i converge to maybe this point right
here
and that's going to be one of these meta
stable states okay
we're going to encounter situations like
this but we're also going to encounter
situations like this
and the bottom thing isn't necessarily
bad and
that's what you have to keep in mind um
and yeah as i said we will get to it but
just keep this kind of
sphere image in mind okay
so first we'll just deal with the
you know the up the top situation where
we store patterns and then retrieve
patterns
so we'll we'll assume a failure
probability which is
p and p is going to be you know pretty
pretty low for their example so they
have p
equals 0.001 you know like a
0.1 percent error probability of
retrieving
your pattern things like this
and randomly chosen patterns on the
sphere with radius m we
define some constants then
with probability 1 minus p the number of
random patterns that can be stored and
stored in the sense
of having these spheres around them so
that you can retrieve them
accurately or at least you can retrieve
something that's close to them is
is bounded lower bounded by this
quantity right here so there's the
square root of p
there is this constant c but then you
see that d
is in the exponent right here so that
means
it's exponential in the number of
dimensions
so that's that's pretty cool so if you
add a dimension
you exponentially increase the number of
the number of patterns you can store and
you know that's that is a kind of i mean
it's
it's been known for modern hopfield
networks with binary strings
so it's not uber surprising but if you
have
you know it's not what you would imagine
like
that okay so they may give a few
examples of these co you have to set
these
constants you know in a particular
fashion such that this is given and so
on
um but they say you know examples here
are where c
is something like three and d is
20. um
so if you were to add a 21st
dimension then your i guess storage
capacity would increase by a factor
of three which pretty cool
all right so this is how many that we
can store infinitely not sorry
exponentially many patterns um in these
networks now they
deal they say
the next theorem states that the update
rule typically converges after
one update if the patterns are well
separated
so if we're in a situation where these
patterns are well separated which is
kind of like this but you can also
imagine this in terms of
dot products because we operate in the
space of dot products
so if the patterns are well separated
that sort of means that
they all kind of sort of point away from
each other
and this notion of separation is going
to be captured by this quantity
right here this is the separation of
example of pattern i
which is just the inner product with
itself
uh minus the maximum inner product with
any other uh pattern and this
quantity is going to be large when no
other pattern is close to it
so when the separation is large then the
update rule the retrieval rule of
um calculating you know i have a query
calculate the inner product with all of
those then i
re-weigh all of the patterns by
that inner product by the softmax then i
used that
new thing as a query again and so on as
we discussed
it will converge to the
closest pattern but this theorem says it
actually converges pretty fast
and here i have my problems with saying
that it converges after one step
um typically converges after one update
because that you know genuinely depends
on a lot of constants as we'll see
but it does converge exponentially fast
in this separation constant as the
theorem 4 says
with query psi after one update
the distance of the new point to the
fixed point
is exponentially small in the separation
delta i
the precise bound using the jacobian and
its value
in the mean value theorem are the
following so
here you can see this is the distance
between the
updated psi after one step
and the um and the fixed point
right here this is what it converges to
is going to be
the distance as it was before
times this thing right here so you can
see since
this is a this is a multiplicative
update
um and in this jacobian
so this is expanded down here this is
this
you can see here you have the you have
sorry yeah this is this so this is
bounded by that
you have the exponent the exponential
function
negative this separation right here
so the higher the separation the faster
this algorithm converges
okay to say that it converges after one
step
is you know it might be a bit of of
bragging i don't know if this is a
common thing if you have like an
exponential convergence
uh that you are allowed to say it's
after one step
i'm not sure especially what i'm not
sure about is that you have
n here as linear constants in that
factor
okay so if you if you
and that's what they do in their code so
if you look at their code and the code's
available which is pretty cool it's
implemented in pi torch as a general
module that can
you can just drop in so this is not only
for transformers this is for
you can replace like lstms you can
replace pooling
mechanisms um you can you know do a
whole bunch of stuff
in their paper in the accompanying paper
they do this multi-instance learning
with giant uh sets um
on using these hopfield layers so pretty
pretty
cool this code is definitely worth kind
of checking out and maybe you want to
replace some
stuff with you but the question is how
many of these
update steps should you do right because
we looked at the diagram at least in the
attention mechanism
it seems like you have attention layers
right you have a transformer
and the transformer consists of you know
you have this input right here
and you go through layer layer layer
layer layer
and in each layer there's contained in
it
and one of these attention mechanism
right this entire thing
is in this layer okay and
now if you interpret this as a hopfield
network
and you want to do multiple steps that
means you go this branch right here so
in
each layer potentially you do multiple
steps of these
things so for whatever computational
constraints
um transformers had already this will
certainly make it worse
but also you need to decide how many
steps you want to do now you can
hard code that of course but they say
you should do
these steps until this norm here until
the norm between the old and the new
is small enough so where is that so you
can't measure
how close you are to the convergence
points right because you don't know
in practice but you can measure how far
you're away you can measure where did we
have it you can measure this quantity
right here
that's something you can measure how far
twit rates are apart
so what you'll simply do is you'll
measure that and if that is small enough
then you'll you'll stop but that
i guess is very related to this so how
if you we've already proven it converges
to this
x star so i guess
we can approximate this quantity right
here with the quantity above
and that tells you how many updates you
need to do and that quantity
is linear not only linear but actually
here quadratic
in n i don't care you know yes it's
exponential
uh amd uh separation
but it's quadratic in n and if i've
learned
anything from kind of my fast code
courses
is that constants actually matter when
you're not dealing with infinity with an
infinite number of steps
so the number of the number of
steps you need to do i guess will
depend on the sequence length in a
quadratic fashion so i'm not sure
you can always claim this is converges
in one step now i might be super
mistaken here and
none of this uh will can none of this
actually makes a difference in the in
the light of the exponential decay here
but i would just i'm just a bit worried
saying this usually converges in one
step it's clear
i guess why they do it right because the
attention mechanism in transformers
is a one-step application of this rule
and this here is kind of a theoretical
justification
for interpreting this precisely as a
hopfield network because you'd say
well in a hopfield network you would do
multiple steps but
wait wait we can actually prove that
even if you interpret it as a hub field
network you
it can it usually converges after one
step so what you're actually doing in a
transformer
is applying a hopfield network update
rule uh to convergence
so yeah i'm not yeah i might be
bickering on a high level here
luxury problems theorem five
then says so theorem four is how fast
does this converge
um theorem five the last theorem right
here
uh says that the retrieval error
of a pattern and so this is the this is
what you converge to and this is what
you've stored
um is bounded by again something that's
exponential in the separation
right here as you can see okay
so that was the theorem so if we go
quickly through them again theorems one
and two deal with the convergence
of this algorithm and the fact that it
actually minimizes the proposed energy
then theorem three says you can store
exponentially many patterns in terms of
the dimension
of your space and theorems
four and five say that this update rule
will converge exponentially fast after
after one step if you believe that
and the retrieval error will also go
down
exponentially fast with the number of
update steps that you do
okay that sounds pretty pretty pretty
good but
we've heard it it's very dependent on
how well
separated these patterns are and it
turns out that
it's you know at least in transformers
they aren't always well
separated and that might be on purpose
remember the
these states here the the patterns
aren't
pre-stored like in a classic hopfield
network but the patterns
if you interpret an attention mechanism
as this are also
generated by the network itself so the
pattern matrix that you retrieve from
and the query are generated by the
attention
mechanism in in this case as i said this
is applicable
to many many more uh domains than just
this
but um yeah so there's another slight
modification that you have to do
to make this actually equivalent to an
attention mechanism and that
is you'll have to recast the value
because usually what you'll do is you
have some sort of input and then you
make
queries keys and values from that using
different heads
the only thing to make it formally
equivalent is you have to make the
values
generated from the keys so the keys
give rise to the values as you can see
right here that you first multiply with
the key matrix
and then with the value matrix i think
that's you know that
i don't i doubt that this will will
change anything
um if you if you
the only way that could really change
anything is if this matrix here would be
super low rank like collapse the space
of um into like very few dimensions
which the value matrix wouldn't do so
you know but just
letting you know that the technical
equality requires
this slight modification
okay now we said that um
it might not you know be that this is
always super well separate and you
retrieve a single pattern
and that's what they research here in a
pre-trained
bert model so they take a pre-trained
model from
i guess from hogging face and
they run they just run a data set
through it
and what they do is so for each for each
query
and sorry for each attention head
because you have multiple
ones of these attention heads right um
in each layer so in each layer you have
multiple ones of these heads
for each head they look at over the
course of the whole data set
how do these softmax distributions look
like
so when you believe that this is a
hopfield network
and you believe that this converges in
one step
then if the patterns are well separated
what we would expect
is a distribution as we said like
this okay there would be one dominant
pattern that you retrieve you know
that's what you want to retrieve
that's what comes out but a bang um
you retrieve that accurate pattern
anything else would mean that the
hopfield network sort of
failed right it wouldn't give you back
one particular pattern
so they have i think that's a pretty
it's a pretty smart experiment they
look how many bars do we need to add how
many of these bars in the soft max
distribution do we need to add to reach
90 percent right so it depends a bit
on the temperature of the softmax which
is hardcoded and attention mechanism pdb
is one this squared over d
um so they say how many do we need
to add to get to 0.9 to 90 percent
of the mass of this distribution
and if this is the hopfield network
where you retrieve one pattern
then one will be enough right one of
these bars will probably be
i don't know like 99 okay
but there are other cases imagine the
case where the patterns
and the query you retrieve the spheres
that it gives rise to are all like
overlapping
okay so what that will do
is it won't converge to any particular
pattern
but the attractor space in this kind so
you can
imagine if you have two spheres that are
apart from each other
the update rule converges either so if
it's closer to here it converge here
if it's closer to here it'll converge
here but if they are overlapping
like this the energy
landscape will actually make it such
that it will neither
if it starts somewhere it will neither
converge to here nor
to here it will actually converge to
somewhere in the middle
okay into the mean of the stored
patterns
and if we take that to the extreme what
could be
is it could be that the softmax
distribution
looks completely uniform okay which
would basically mean that
you know i don't care where my
information comes from just average
and this has its applications so if you
for example want to make a sentiment
classifier
a very cheap way to do that is to simply
take pre-trained word embeddings like
glove or word to back
you know assign each word word embedding
and then just average the word
embeddings
okay and you count on the fact if there
are a lot of kind of negative words in
there like
bad sad angry
the word embedding kind of will you know
reflect that and the average word
embedding will point more into the bad
direction
and if there's a lot of happy words the
average will point into the happy
direction
okay so there are applications of
averaging information
not caring particularly where it comes
from
and um in that case
what we'd expect is that this number and
we'll call that
so we'll call that the number k in this
case it equals one
but in this case k equals i guess n
the number of inputs okay because we
need well not maybe n
but you know approximately we need
almost all of them
to uh to reach the 90 percent
okay and there there is an in between
and these are called these meta stable
states where
and the in between is something like
you'd have a couple of patterns
here a couple here and a couple maybe
here
it's almost like a clustering like and
these overlap and these
overlap and these overlap
but they don't overlap with each other
which means that if you start somewhere
here you would converge to the mean but
not to the mean of all the patterns but
just to the mean of these patterns and
here here and here
here so this this is like a clustering
in latent space right
so you can interpret these hopfield
update rules as somehow
you know getting not going to a
particular pattern but going to sort of
a cluster and this
is if you ask something like hey is
there any adjective around
right and all of these patterns they
kind of overlap in that space
in that query space of adjective they
overlap and therefore the
update rule would converge to sort of
the mean which would basically say yes
there is
an adjective here right and the
information
would not be routed so that the
distribution
if we start here right and we converge
to this the distribution would look
something like
small small small and then you'd have a
couple of large ones
right you'd have like maybe two or three
or four of large ones
and these would exactly correspond to
the patterns here
so the information will be routed from
all of those
in that cluster to this particular
node that asks the query okay these are
these are what's called these meta
stable states and what
they do is they calculate over the
entire data set this number
k and here they show you the
distribution so in these plots
what you'll see is over the entire data
set um
k goes into that direction so i guess
let's go to tis here this this seems
pretty easy so k
uh is in this direction and this is
simply the
amount of like how so in each
you you let a data point run through it
you measure k for that particular
layer one you see this is layer one head
four okay this is one layer one
attention head
and then you can see that the number k
is distributed like this
okay so contrast this to this head right
here
where it's a lot of weight on the number
one or like very few numbers okay so
these blue ones
would be these are your typical like
when you retrieve one particular pattern
so this attention head we can sort of
conclude
in this particular tension head this is
very specific
it looks at its input it looks at its
token
and it decides what information do i
want and it retrieves one particular
thing
from the other nodes okay whereas
here it's more like kind of an an
averaging it's more like i want this
kind of information
and on average i don't even know what
the sequence length is here
i guess it's maybe 512. uh
so of the 512 the median
this number is always the median in
median it collects information from 231
of them
okay so you can see that
this corresponds this green and orange
ones correspond to these meta-stable
states
where uh there's kind of an implicit
clustering done
in the in this space of attention
whereas the blue ones they correspond to
attention heads that ask for particular
information retrieve
one particular maybe a few patterns
and um happy with that and the red ones
here
you can see that they often just
average they just you know because k
is so high means that i need all of the
i need
all of these bars to get to the 90 or i
need almost all of them
which basically means it's a uniform
distribution right so
it's like i don't care where information
comes from just
average whatever average i just want the
average you know
some particular uh space and
as we said that also has its uses
interesting how this translate through
so this here is as we go down the vert
model on the bottom you have layer one
you see there are a lot of these
averaging operations going on so a lot
of the heads are simply doing
averaging and as you go up the layers
the heads get more and more specific in
the types
of information they seek but
then again in the last layers
interestingly you get into a lot of
these meta stable
states again which i guess
again interpret this as you as you want
i'm going to leave this up to you
but it sort of says like here you want
kind of general patterns at the bottom
and then the middle layers are kind of
the logical workhorses so you look for
very specific
things in the input this is i guess this
is where
i guess this is where the thinking
happens um so
this is sort of pre-processing
i'm just making stuff up here by the way
this is this must be in no way true
this is maybe thinking and
this this here this might already be
output again because you know after that
you have language modeling or
classification so this might
already be like aggregating uh
types of information this is how i sort
of interpret it
okay uh yeah so so this these these
experiments are pretty pretty pretty
interesting and here they
have they do these are the last
experiments for this paper
um they do an interesting experiment
where they actually replace the
attention heads
by simply an average mechanism
and later they actually replace them by
gaussians but in this case they simply
average
and they show that look if i replace
layer one
with just averaging the perplexity
doesn't rise that much
right so it's pretty good um even if i
replace an entire layer here with
averaging
uh it it perplexity goes more up
and you can see the corresponds if you
remember the previous plot
the correspondence is pretty one to one
with how much blue
and green uh heads there are as in
contrast to how much
red uh and orange ones there are
so here you have lots of blue ones and
you can see that the error kind of goes
up
and interestingly here you
have more meta-stable states at the end
but still the perplexity goes up
uh more so i guess you can only really
replace the red ones
with the averaging so this is always
averaging
in one particular layer
and they go into more detail here
where they say look this is this is
layer six
and this is layer 12. so this is one
particular tension head from layer 6 and
layer 12
and the updates don't be confused it
goes in this direction
okay i was confused at first and you can
see right here
this number k at first you know it's
kind of spread out
but then it pretty quickly converges to
a very small
number and there is this kind of point
right here i don't know if the learning
rate's decreased i don't think so i
think that's just kind of a
a phase transition right here this is
the blue line by the way the blue
training line
a face transition where all of a sudden
these just these attention heads they
somehow decide okay
this is the thing i want to specialize
in this is the type of task i want
like a sub task of linguistic subtask i
want to specialize in and then they
concentrate
on one particular pattern per input so
they are
really specializing whereas in the last
layer you see here
that even during training they are sort
of continuously learning
so first they also do this averaging
then they go into this
meta-stable region right this is this
meta-stable region
k isn't one but also k isn't a very high
number
um so they continuously learn
and it's even indicative of this
training might not be done here first of
all and second of all it would be really
interesting to see how this works out
with you know
sizes of transformers and like
especially these these huge transformers
just the fact that they can keep
learning
the more we train them might be you know
be
interpreted in the light of what kind of
states they converge to
and the fact that there are tension
heads i don't know how does this go on
do they stay in the meta stable states
because it makes sense
to have metastable states as i said it
makes sense to kind of cluster
things or are they simply
is this simply an intermediate step and
if you go really far down they would
actually also converge
to the k equals one where they
really specialize or maybe do we need
more attention heads for this i don't
know
it it's just i think this is just the
the beginning
of kind of research in this direction i
think
just this kind of number k um how
it's how it's made it's pretty simple
and
apparently it's pretty pretty revealing
so you know that's pretty cool
so that was the paper uh and
its experiments it's it's a pretty
sizable paper as i said even the paper
itself is uh
10 pages and then there is this immune
repertoire classification which
uh i will like spend one minute looking
at it
so you have you have these set
classifications so for each human you
obtain a set of immune receptors
and you simply obtain one label whether
that human is
immune to a particular disease or not
and
your task is kind and then a different
human has a different set you have no
idea which one of these things is
responsible for it being
for the human being um for the human
being immune or not
in fact there is a it you can't even
decide
based on these you can only decide based
on like sub sequences
uh of these and they might be in
combination with each other so there
might not be a single one responsible
but like a combination but you don't
have labels for the individual ones
and you have different ones per human
and they are different lengths
all of this is just a giant um
giant task and you have many of them you
have tens of thousands
per human right so they build a system
here where
first they do these 1d convolutions to
process the
inside sequences and then they do this
hopfield um attention mechanism
all with with learned queries uh over
these things and then they train on the
output label and surprisingly uh that
actually works
even with tens of thousands of inside
sequences and only one label
for all of them and
so they they achieve i guess uh
favorable results compared to other
baselines on this task using these
hopfield network which is pretty
interesting
but i'll let you look at that paper
yourself
so i hope this somehow uh made
it a bit clear what happens here and it
would actually be pretty interesting
um if we you know
to see what happens if we just do
maybe two rounds of these updates is
this even desirable
right uh is it desirable to run this to
convergence is there something good
about not
running into convergence or does it
actually not matter because it
actually does converge in one step i i
don't know
but have a look at the code um it's
pretty cool
and i hope you enjoyed this video
i'm sure you have many open questions as
do i uh don't hesitate to ask me
in the comments or join our discord as i
said there are lots of helpful people
on our discord and i'll see you next
time bye